hello everyone what is up happy Thursday
great thirsty Thursdays thanks you think
we're thirsty for these new games
because this week has been pretty insane
with the releases and yeah today we're
checking out Boyd Basterds which also
came out this week and we're playing on
PC today and we're letting Michael
handle all the awesomeness because he
has been grinding it out a little bit I
would like to play more but I haven't
really had time so now I'm spending work
time get on that grind a little bit for
void bags just so you know sometimes
it's a one of the same working play you
know doesn't happen often but here we
are so if y'all don't know what void
masses is it's like a first-person sort
of immersive sim sort of a strategy game
sort of a stealth action thing it can
actually be whatever you want to be
depending on your play style but how
this draws a lot of inspirations from
FTL as you'll see oceans from system
shock which is one of my favourite games
of all time and just those two
comparisons alone
boy I was sold yeah and the art style of
this game is so good like I really
really like it yeah me too
it's it's like a like I don't know if
you ever played 13 old game from like
GameCube ps2 era that had like
cel-shading looked really cool and I
think it's aged well that's same for
everyone tuning in thank you and welcome
good morning seeing some familiar faces
in the chat is Chris got crime and Jason
Fox 9 bucks oh man Jimmie Johnson sighs
oh hi right back at ya um so yeah this
is your save file this is actually an
old [ __ ] this is an old save fire uh
steam usually sinks
of course cloud saves but I was playing
on a pretty release press version I
think some ways save files got messed up
also I think I was playing offline at
home so I lost some progress oh well
we'll roll with what we got
it's all good it's a run based game so
it's it's got rogue elements okay as
well
so yeah this may look familiar if you
played FTL so it's got some rogue
elements you get objectives throughout
the game but you need to make it to
those objectives before your clients or
character dies and if they do die you
carry over some of that progress but you
got to go through and run through these
ships again to get to the objective you
can make it to the objective and not
complete and die right there and they
got to do it all over again yeah that's
like a classic game like punishment
right oh well you're going all the way
back to the start yeah just got to hold
that yeah so I don't know how much
you've seen avoid bastards but I'm
actually not much at all I did see some
gameplay footage and I wanted to check
it out yesterday but didn't get a chance
to lot of stuff going on man it's busy
out okay so let me try and quickly
explain what I'm trying to do here so
yeah we're on the star map and each of
these ships are missions but you don't
have to go to them cuz it really depends
on if you have enough fuel and food
those are your two resources to travel
and then I could be like oh I have
enough fuel and a food for one more jump
I could skip this and go to the next one
or I can gather the resources here and
fight those enemies that are here so
there's a lot of information here how to
set up some whoa what's going on right
we're trying thank you well we got time
yeah we don't have to rush yeah I feel
like I'm in a rush
yeah this is where kind of the strategy
and planning elements come in for void
bastards because gotta manage your
resources god I know what you have which
capable of but also what you're facing
so if you look at the right these are
the enemies the spooks scribes of
janitors there's some of each and then a
few spooks so there's gonna be some some
some terrifying enemies and also you got
a little bit of a hazard update many
electrical hazards oh boy I don't know
if I want to deal with that but you know
what I have to
so let's doc do it so I got a prep
action
I'm going to bring with me I'm just
gonna go basically bushwhackers those
are really good they're like proximity
mine so I guess I'll bring break names
let's go with a basic setup so ox Knight
says the art design reminds me of
Futurama that's what I said
I was talking to rob handler II who's
also playing this game a lot and I was
like yeah this reminds me of Futurama
and yeah and it's really cool I like it
a lot it just looks art so I'm just
personally a fan of games with art
styles like this like so I really like
skull girls oh yeah I'm going to try to
find a better position for a camera here
okay no problem so I need to turn off
I'll get be seeing I need to up my fov
of course so it got some some classic PC
settings right there boom all right so
this is run based okay now whoa that had
that off of these way too I'm sorry I'm
very picky by now my sensitivities to
whatever I'll roll
okay so as you'll see this is kind of
you know what if you played system shock
it's got that same energy and that's
what I like most about this game is like
that system shock sci-fi immersive sim
stealth action type of [ __ ] it's got it
all it's got a lot of British humor too
oh but I'm already [ __ ] up here they
already know I'm here I like the sound
effects the reason oh yeah yeah the
music's pretty jamming yeah it's
definitely got like a ethereal tech
sci-fi vibe yeah it's really cool I just
love the way this game looks it's so
clean and expressive so it's very easy
to tell like what's what in the world -
can I jump over this
I need to look at where am I going CI
each instance is randomly generated I
believe every time you go into a ship it
lays out a random layout and that's
where we kind of scavenger resources and
also do different things like also if
you look at the top I have a oxygen
meter so I need to pump up oxygen in
case I run out this ship actually
doesn't have any oxygen recharge so I
need to I need to do this [ __ ] real
quick don't ya we will die so I'm going
to get to the helm and unveil all the
things I need to know about this
yeah if if any all wondering if you'd
playboy bastards or have questions about
the game hit us up get my ass before it
please don't I mean it's all again this
uh this mouse was very sensitive and I
accidentally shot by just pressing down
or just moving the mouse
not a good showing like all the little
art details to you like when he started
running you have like the action lines
yeah it's really cool it's very
expressive in that it communicates also
like if you notice here like before you
open a door it'll like that gives you a
hint as to what enemy is behind that
door I saw this bunch of loot there
there's big loot right there yeah we
need that big loot loot will help us
keep us alive in this game and are you
more hungry oh [ __ ] there's hell oh I'm
so dead I'm so dead no you got this yeah
they're all bunched up okay all right
fair enough that works we got rid of
them that's all all we needed to do they
have a spawn point right here
damn it good Kev's gret says the art
style looks like an old xbox game I
think in a third CD yeah I like the art
style regardless yeah
yeah like I said like when you run you
can see the little sound you can see the
sound yeah you've seen it it's really
neat touches so immersive oh we can't
sidestep that can I
dammit okay I'm gonna get this I'm
probably gonna get the fuel feels very
important yes cuz we need to get out of
here can't get out here enough you yeah
I got two and a half minutes left before
I run out of breath that's terrifying
that's one of the big loop that Oh No
close that door sorry I didn't mean to
intrude on your privacy how are you on
Derek says the scheme is great its on
xbox game pass - sure is yeah how you
can get your hands on this game well
it's on it's on game pass it's out it
came out yesterday son game pass polish
my humble I think we got some fuel I
believe so now you got all the way back
oh I like this death screen this is
great yep so the story is that go home
you just gotta get good it's like a 2000
ad comic in motion so speed Fox
animation yeah it's definitely got that
comic book feel if you saw the title
screen it was basically like the front
cover of a comic book yeah even Hallie
little barcode it's all told through
comic panels - so what happens when you
die is that you get a new client which
is a new character they're randomly
generated and they have either perks or
debuff on perks Oh interesting so this
is like a permadeath once you lost that
character dunzo for good yeah with this
character I got two perks which is
really cool because that really happens
so I got a little bit more I get money
for every
one man for every health I loose oh
that's cool nice and short stature oh
I'm sure I mean yeah we can't even see
his face and his mic that's wonderful
your action items power to the short
people I'm 5 2 so I'm allowed to you
know these are short people in the world
okay so I need to get in there like my
ID picture it looks exactly like this
guy's mic shut so every time there is an
Atari pet carrier I always go to these
ships because there are my favorite
ships I know the durable and over the
over the PA system you can hear a lady
speaking Japanese and save space yeah
hello Errol he says hi Michael Oh what's
up dude it was my boy hey welcome back
see some other familiar face to hackers
back so I'm yesterday in the stream this
game is not on PSN actually it's on PC
and Xbox right now and so welcome back
yeah yesterday neo2 stream was super fun
had already on it was great ok like
Jordan has been playing a lot of like
Sakura so he was trying to like get back
in the rhythm of neo so it was pretty
funny and it was a good time so if you
guys missed that you should definitely
go check it out because it is cool it
was the closed alpha demo but definitely
write up that like familiar neo alley
so here as you can tell it looks like
I'm crouching because my character like
I said is short and it's represented in
the game that's so yeah boy pastors has
a ton of these like quirks to it that
are it's very unique make it very deep
so for this ship so here's another
variable that they throw out you every
door is blocked and you have to wait to
open them which can cause problems
especially try to run away exactly I've
had that many a time so on these little
tortoise got a step away before you
shoot them off oh yeah Seok was asking
me about legalizing yesterday I'm gonna
try to get some league onto the stream
soon oh really
but I only play a Rams it's like it's
called it stands for all random all mid
so everyone gets a random champion and
then every and there's only one lane so
you don't have to worry about like
getting gangs and you can't go back you
can only go back and shop when you die I
go the door open like welcome robot of
death centuries herbs they're they're
very dead the accuracy I know who's got
a mod literally a name I lost myself but
I think I get merits for that if that's
how my ass oh snap so chilled is back
welcome back hey thanks for coming back
you guys also I constantly check my map
I go to and from so sure you don't get
lost that can be your downfall might be
disorienting for you all over
I got a got a play to win stick
so I download the ship data and did I
know I didn't [ __ ] I gotta go this way
oh we need the Intel Michael no golden
blind we're already short brian says if
someone damages the characters I will
have to scream Doba that would be
intense
yeah would put it faster to a sandwich
only half oh there's the other half I
could drink some coffee and do triple
damage but I don't need Errol says he
loves cel-shaded graphics they help a
lot of older games aged better imo I did
download the data I'm so dumb I didn't
even need to do that this is an example
of how it's hard to concentrate a whole
you're playing on a stream and also
trying to explain the game and also keep
the conversation going
I mean I'm trying to help mitigate that
yeah you're doing right okay it got you
streams my gosh you see Mel says what is
this game bastard it's I still just
can't get over it
looks so cool yeah I'm just spent I mean
I know we are in the future and we have
access to all of these technologically
advanced graphics but you still see
games like this and you're the mind is
blown so look so
it's all about the creativity now it's
not about realistic oh [ __ ] it's not
about realistic graphics it's about
innovation creativity originality so
chilled says so what is the premise so
far premise so far is that you each
clients that you play as all the powers
off
that's why everything salons turn the
power power these powers over here aha
so I want to do that I think I might
need to do that to get the Big Blue
Ribbon easy so I go back around wasting
ammo let me just I can probably what is
the premise so far oh okay so the
premise is each character that you play
is a space prisoner ah and you are
awaken from your slumber oh my god I
didn't realize you can never
[Music]
deeper peepers gonna get you I need to
step far back those sorry like I was
saying the privacy's so each character
you play is a space prisoner and you are
awakened from your slumber you are
dehydrated in space and they rehydrate
you to complete these objectives and I
think the overall premise is that you're
trying to escape I could be wrong I paid
money to open this door a [ __ ] and yeah
so far the objectives have been like
okay you need to get this part to create
this thing that will help you escape
okay psych you know you need to create
this thing so that's kind of been the
loop so far not terribly far into the
game but I have been enjoying everything
playing can be very difficult you know
you're hurt right now so I'm gonna get
this fuel and then applying the tip out
cuz also my oxygen is very low
yeah almost a minute later no I got do
the [ __ ]
where's the other one it's all the way
back there [ __ ] Abbey Trent says you
don't have to shoot the tourists they'll
explode if you just walk in here at them
oh let's give that oh yeah oh [ __ ]
prosit I got over on the way thank you
so if you've been playing void Basterds
and you have some pro tips for me send
them my way
indeed I need to get the [ __ ] out of
here
there's no over there but I'm also just
Defence radiation radiation oh my gosh
I've been watching Chernobyl oh my god
yeah a lot of people been talking
I cannot even work on freaking and you
know what else close my mind is that it
kind of wasn't that long ago yeah we're
see yeah we are I just lost a bunch of
health also cuz I didn't get a bunch of
fuel those darn tourists they're making
up on you I think I can probably escape
no no no damn it
Wow you barely survived we almost lost
the short guy eat some food yeah I'm
huapi cube interesting iike sets so I
got some materials so I can build some
other things
okay yeah sure surgery for dummies
Frances odd job son came cute Wow so I
got some cool items here Oh Chris L the
true novel thing I was talking about is
actually like a mini show series on HBO
I started checking it out after Game of
Thrones ended but yeah it's definitely
really interesting it's about the
real-life Chernobyl event and all that
jazz yeah you want you want to pick up
as many parts you can and throughout the
mission so you build supposed to be a
distraction does the game have classes
so I guess it's not so much a class as
it is like whichever prisoner you get
our client you get yeah it's like B
class in a way yeah because they have
their own set of perks that's kind of
how it how you can get classes I guess
so yeah let's pick so I can scout what
these what each ship kind of entails so
I can kind of plan ahead of time do you
like do I want to land here do I want to
deal with shed loads of tourists those
are the dudes who explode
probably not cuz they do a lot of damage
if I'm not careful enough so I might
skip over that because I have enough
fuel and food to maybe do a second jump
or can land here this was a lot of
scribes do I want to deal with them
what can I find here
Merritt staples PLAs I don't know maybe
I can go here yeah bushwhackers there's
a lot of janitors Anders can be tough
oh I pick up some fuel but I won't have
that much food is what I'll do I'll jet
here
all these pirate ships oh no some uh jet
here so they just follow you follow you
yeah oh and now you're starving so let's
get some grub lose 50 health on my next
jump which is why Falls
Clell says he remember seeing the
Chernobyl meltdown on the news when he
was a kid oh my goodness
that's surreal a little bit especially
when they start making like movies and
shows out of the event candy box always
bring the kitty but so my dumb ass
flew too many times I lost 50 health so
I have to land here and I better find
food because I'm struggling out here and
stapler I need be careful cuz stapler
doesn't have that much ammo on a very
good forgot to check forgot to check
what I was dealing with here Helms right
here it's Horace
the name of this game is it for boy
bastards oh we lost wood oh poor went
out for the short people
I am very not care I'm sorry purse oh no
it's fine
the game is beautiful enough that any
gameplay with sorry for the shortfall
got there I couldn't keep keep our
friend alive long enough now we have
Matt Matthews Leroy Matthews well it's
really cool our my perk here is nearby
tourist won't spontaneously detonate so
that could be good or bad if you want
you're trying to blow them up I save me
ammo you can't do it now with this guy
but I think I don't have to deal with
them at all because the only way I think
they'll always follow you or they just
won't explode when I watch 500k they
just like there'd be like oh I see you
family you're one of us maybe it's cuz
he looks a little perks like that
completely change how you approach some
of these ships it's like oh there's a
bunch of tourists on the ship well I'm
safe I can just scavenge freely
hopefully we can try and do that we need
to eat food okay
so let's give this a shot there's shed
loads of tourists and let's see
okay let's dock right here oh hell yeah
I like to push back this is good keep on
back start here helm is over here so I
just gotta get busted ooh these offices
here and we'll see you later Sam ghost
thanks for tuning in it is
11:27 luck tourists see dog Hey
but I gotta be careful the janitors they
still cool sick Derek says this art
sales asking to be on in 10 dose which
so that would look good on foot
Oh is hella tourists are not tourists
janitors Oh
Oh what do I got what we got cubot Diddy
bah ah we're good we're good
oh snap well it's gonna split up to kill
it can be create yes
Oh kitty Boxer clutch just pieces
everywhere oh you know what took one for
the team
[Music]
can't worry about that I gotta get my
yeah right
we only got so much air I gotta get them
cheeseburgers
oh there's a lot a lot of money hand
come out Oh
I know I'm not I'm gonna deal whatever
no no wait could be sneaky
yeah closes door I can't see anything
tor is my home I know right there like
so friendly now I love seeing them or
before I would just be like no tourists
now it's a comfort yeah bring all the
shed loads so funny
where's she at this game is very British
humor therefore I will not understand
any of these jokes
I don't fortunately at least a muppet
I stepped in oil now I'm slipping all
over the place
oh my goodness yeah it's anyone excited
for call of duty modern warfare asks
Kira I heard about it but actually and
see anything about it yet I think in
terms of Call of Duty games you know
there's only so much excitement I can
have right although I did feel a little
bit of joy when they kind of brought it
back just for a little more of its
original file and the recent ones and
less like you know camera you're just
totally hammer II was flying around I'm
like what yeah this is another level
yeah Billy on that yeah
call me old-school but holla duty was
just supposed to be one of those running
then spray-and-pray games where you just
like go to feel a little bit better
about yourself
easy I think I'll call it beauties I
think I'm kind of tired of the
glorification of war and I think at
least what I gather is that they're
trying to be a little bit more
thoughtful about that call of duty as a
city but oh my god it was not enough
goodness security to to talk to you shut
it down
oh yeah I got 45 seconds that was a
brave test just stare at him head on
dude turn off Kiki what am i doing what
am i doing I just want to get all this
loot and get out of here yeah well you
get plenty of oxygen this time
I'm playing right there sir [ __ ] there's
something else over here I got time for
that
bro aqua says they should have more
enemy types in DLCs for this game we've
been so trained to expect the LCA that
even when a game comes out yesterday
yesterday we're still thinking like man
I wonder what kind of DLC is gonna come
out I just noticed that more and more
like as games come out people looking
forward to like what else is gonna be it
but that would be cool I mean we're only
I mean I've only seen a little bit of
this game so far we've seen a few
different in the meantime there are a
lot more and we touches a dress and they
get a lot harder it's just that I need
to get there and I haven't been able to
get there because I need to get good
first you know I'm gonna leave a lot of
this loot behind
come on tell me I got two and a half
minutes a couple other things in that
same room oh wait were those ones he had
to pay for no he dodged into it
get two minutes plenty of time thing is
I don't know faults that's worth yeah I
guess that is the the gamble you take
with looting thanks for tuning in mister
kanesha have a good night and thanks for
coming back it's always nice and few
days tuning back in fair enough one or
the other is always good toaster juice
yella Turia's get up lean in which right
move and run here
can this game also switched to
third-person it would be cool just to
see the character I guess art there is
like a mirror oh they all were the same
all right so Matthews is looking pretty
good so far because you know get this
awesome perk that was a smoother ride
only those Dharan janitor isn't it yeah
super helpful to the chilla Taurus air
freshener oh we got some stinky enemies
or something I did notice there was
garbage everywhere
maybe that reduces some status effects
like oil does asbestos jacket some of
these things give you an idea of like
what your you're in for later down the
road yeah less fire damage there less
radiation damage which is helpless about
health 200 calls that's pretty good
that's that's not nothing so I'm trying
to build the HR computer so I need the
bounce ball so previously I found other
two parts so I got that third part okay
so I can tell HR that I'm getting abused
by this prison okay so I have three food
so I can't really go
that far but I'm a jet over here so
here's only a lot of tourists I might
want to stop here to second a boy got
some spooks though keep going down this
way so I do that we have a lot of jumps
now I picked up a ton of fuel and that
last job aqua says the janitor reminds
me of how scared I was when I first
played ret remake this year and saw a
liquor those liquors man no thought
liquors are worse yeah those guys oh my
gosh there's no enemies on this back
lots of grace
I'm stopping Bob Jones says Michael
always wants more life I have about that
life
no mini-map available yeah each each
ship has its own conditions and you
yourself have your own conditions it's
never a dull moment employed bastards it
really is like it goes okay now I see
why they call him that
they're like visible janitors we're at
dog weirdo
do something yeah you gonna do [ __ ] got
the home you got the homies tourists
talking about can you do nothing
that's so funny though still oh and your
map is dunzo yeah all the mini-map is oh
my god oh boy
find me notes I'm so bad
I am so heated Multi emai asks which
one's better for tonight or apex which
one do you like more yeah I personally
like Apex Marvin fortnight's I mean
nothing against 4 at night it's just
yeah exactly like the meta behind that
game is I feel like is more around
building than it is around like you know
gunplay yeah so I think that's kind of
why I lean towards apex little more not
because I think it's bad but just
because it's difficult like I've tried
to do it I watch people like clips and
streams and like people play who are
really good at building and I'm like
that is magical I cannot do this trying
to build my own life I've got time to
build [ __ ] ramps and [ __ ] I love apex
I've been having a lot of fun with it
lately respawn is a great oh no no no no
don't hurt me only that down there
another spook
SiC I have I actually have not seen the
Modern Warfare trailer but everyone in
the office was talking about it earlier
which is the same thing that happened
yesterday with the dust anding trailer I
didn't see it yet but everyone was
talking about it and then I finally got
to watch it and it wasn't easy
so things going on - yeah that's [ __ ]
happen in the morning
unexpectedly yes call duty that happenin
o'clock and I was like we were screaming
void bastards are we are we am I ready I
don't know oh [ __ ] trailers dropped on
so many things to think about yeah but
it's awesome like what it's time to be
alive never a dull moment Andy you three
is right around the corner so you know
everyone's trying to whip out and be
like what up yeah yeah and word they
busted out the big ass parts where we're
trying to pack our stuff to head over to
e3 already I'm like dude can everyone
just chill out for a second there's too
much going I'm trying to survive Android
bastards - hey see you later multi emai
thanks for stopping by
yes thank you for watching me suffer
Ben's like that stranded though I just
saw philanthropy I'm like all right
already nobody saw my boy thing pretty
great that was a good run I came out
with three food three fuel not much
damage i horas exactly the homies now
you're just like visiting friends you're
like who's yeah which one of my friends
lives on this ship alright cool we're in
there I hope I could get far with
Matthews because this perk is really
really good oh yes pinky now that's
that's a cool perk eros said he almost
forgot about his birthday while prepping
for e3 about your birthday yeah there's
a lot going on don't forget well he
happy early birthday or belated if it
passed already
yeah hey Errol I hope to see you I need
better
and it's the hobbies from SD
pirates so I don't know I'm not exactly
sure how Pirates are going to affect
play here yes so they're on you huh yeah
they're following you now you pick them
up during your travels so I'm gonna keep
going if anyone knows like every time
I've come across pirates I've been able
to avoid them so this is my or I had a
missile that destroys them when I
encounter that so I don't have any right
now so fortunately stuffing treats you
know Oh the Pirates will follow you onto
the ship
[Music]
oh yeah cross bling for cut by the way I
did hear about that really which i think
is pretty cool that's the future man
like let's stop separating ourselves
I'll get on st. cloud platform however
imagine playing like Call of Duty
against PC players with controller I
feel like that would be kind of broken
but we'll see
wait what Oh Boyd whale I died a void
will swallowed you wait wait wait hold
up hold up
did you land on him no I know Leroy we
lost him
I'm so close to the objective - I was
like a couple jumps away and I was like
ok it's pirate ship I'll deal with them
when I when I have to I didn't see the
whale die the tourists are no longer our
friends that is unfortunate now we got
Ellis Ellis is really cool
interacts with objects at a great
distance ok so long arm she got just got
that reach yeah okay let's go got the
wingspan alright action items Dean what
a bummer you're gonna be super tall
though he was the wire you're supposed
to be the water
all right let's hope I don't that's good
oh I see the whales flying it devours
small ships can you upgrade your ship to
a bigger ship or maybe probably I hope
so yeah there's definitely no plot armor
here I've been had skills like no BOTS
ever know once will you die you get a
new character
you just got to complete that objective
to progress but how long it takes to get
there it's totally up to you I guess
it's up to me I'm gonna skip this
there's this food I was a luxury ship
I'm actually you know I'm gonna live the
life of luxury for a moment hey Adrienne
welcome back thanks for tuning in we're
playing some void bastards today just
came out yesterday is on PC and Xbox so
check it out is pretty cool ourselves
great your characters so tall yes
touching the light fixtures so this is a
really cool thing about this game even
though you lose your character
permanently if you die and get a new one
each one has these different elements
and perks so we had woods at one point
and he was a short character who is
really tiny and it reflects is like as
he walked around in case you're just
tuning in and then now we have Ellis and
she's super tall yeah the end of crouch
to go through the door taking on some
hits yeah this game has been really cool
so far making our way through ships we
got eaten by a whale turn on our it away
from me janitor who gave these janitors
a gun alright they should have brooms or
something in the short-range attackers
and they're like super strong because I
was - headshots the thing about this
ship is that there's no power need turn
the power on to open up anything
subscribes in the way damn I am tallest
ah the hard reads on you right now he's
reading your street patterns and
everything there we go place yes my USP
boys opening eco round I'm running a
careful bullet stuff is this it's hard
to there you don't get many of them
Peyton Amanda says hello haven't visited
this channel in a while now what's up
man
welcome back yeah glad to see you've
returned we are checking out wide
bastards which just came out yesterday
and it's beautiful that's cool I'm sorry
I love the gameplay because I love
System Shock Bioshock it's made by some
folks who worked on Bioshock so you see
some of the lineage there in terms of
how it plays
and it's atmosphere yeah it's pretty
awesome
really ooh-kay
oh man hence eyes though you know Bobby
no um it's I might be a writer but its
words are different but if I say follow
me on Twitter
the folks know that know what yeah at
Michael P Higham pantai hit different is
what I'll say is what I did say it's
2019 no judge me out we out here
representing people we came back into
this room just to solidify that back
yeah well I mean good art style good
well place graphics oh that poster is
like on every wall I realize oh yeah
cool I like the space wha-wha-what okay
now I can go back to the helm and
download the schematics Christopher Hart
sends a thumbs up and says this came out
yesterday people go get it I kinda agree
it's really got a we do have a review on
the sites by my good friend
ossandra Barbosa Oh
I'm gonna try to get him onto this show
soon different all we have to offer
Wow what are the odds of that I feel
like that's such a unique new year
that's what a lot of people say when I
was in elementary school
we had three Samantha's in my class my
real name which I hate by the way I
usually ask people to call me Sam
or Persia that's my handle baby who in
elementary school we had three
Samantha's and we had a really really
tall Samantha so everybody called her
big Sam and then I was the shortest one
so everybody called me little soon we
had Samantha she just like you know
plain old Samantha so we had big Sam
little Sam and then Samantha that's how
they differentiated us and she was super
tall she was like almost twice my height
at that time I was pretty sure though
she was ten feet tall at that time I was
like I was like refeeds maybe two and a
half what I was talking about the life
of luxury yes this is the luxury ship
after you have to pay you money to lift
this handle it's gonna be worth it whiz
rocks I have no idea what that does but
I'm down hey it was worth every penny
good see this is the real tech you guys
when when things go awry in the world go
find somewhere that's recently been
catered that's why you can get okay I
need to get oxygen big-time I wonder if
Ellis uses more oxygen because she's a
bigger
let's see what how much my what my max
fill up in a second subdued do something
didn't stream I know too tall
[Music]
fortune is in our favor crimes like
little Sam oh why did you tell me this
well now you guys think on me that
perhaps no but for real I was really
sure well I still am really sure it but
when I was younger in elementary school
I remember going into middle school my
first day and the teachers being like oh
no little girl did you get on the wrong
bus from elementary I'm like oh no I'm
supposed to be here I'm used to growing
up with people short of it because like
90% of my friends and people I grew up
with our Filipino so yeah I was the tall
one and I think I have bad posture
because growing up I was just around
people who are shorter than me
so you're just like hunching over
subconsciously exactly yeah so that's uh
that's just my excuse for having bad
posture it's like the homies is short
out there
Clell says he's never met another person
with his first name except his granddad
well makes sense you've inherited that
name but yeah that's a unique names cool
I think I've looted the ship for as much
as I possibly can
according to because I download
schematics and there's no more items on
this oh yeah we've got it yeah I got I
got my film we have alluded efficiently
watch involved yeah how tall are you
yes six foot tall which is not that's
all actually that's pretty tough
that's like back home that's all my
aunties and uncles like Michael's
looking out for his stuff looking out
rows down here hey man I got y'all
except for woods there was no hope for
woods oh yeah he didn't want it look at
this [ __ ] dude look how much for one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
sandwiches baby yeah like bandits yeah I
got one two three four five six seven
eight sandwiches
grills I'm gonna go over to uh honey
baby and get me a nice and toasted
sandwich on dr. crotch you know what I
tried around here recently the bird ooh
the bird do that I went it was like
after the stream so I was like tears
okay so yeah because during the like
peak lunch hours that line goes out door
dog that [ __ ] goes around the block but
luckily when I went it was there wasn't
line but it was all inside still okay
that's that's a good time to go there
a pirate's locking me down dude
okay Matthew who just joined the stream
is this on xbox one yesterday should
check it out think it's on game pass yes
it's on game pass so if you got game
pass play some boy passes all right now
I'm in the same predicament I was in the
last time all right boy whale is one
step away from me so I don't know what
to do like if I go down to this area
right here the whale can just go right
there if I go I can't go to it we can't
go back the only option is to go so this
might have been my fault by just like
not thinking ahead but he'll follow you
there I know you do sandwiches I don't
think the whales gonna get you unless
you land over there
did he follow you to the other point
loss I think so Oh No imagine going oh
that's a trap without [ __ ] completing
this I need to do it for y'all out there
that looks like your only choice yeah
alright let's do this raise up
lord help me yes all right
the whale went to the other side that
was a 50/50 really literally but I got a
I got a mutation so these jeans fly
around the map as well and if you count
to them they give you a different part
okay okay yeah so now I'm no longer tall
so I got short but it gained the
surround your ability so interesting I
don't know what describes ability does
maybe helps me get more items I think oh
yeah I'm not tall anymore like yeah mug
shots still the same but it's find a
percent of time when you went out of a
MOS status another clip from self okay
cool yeah mo is extremely valuable in
this game what I think oh my goodness
I'm sorry I just noticed this but Ellis
was locked up for stealing from a
vending machine
oh yeah B screams yeah yes but hey yeah
this is this whole game is based around
crime so shouts at the crime boys and
you get some backstory like why they got
locked up in space hilarious I don't
know if you ever seen that showed the
100 I don't think so so basically like
what's left of human life is living on
this ship in the air because the earth
like it was you know in height you
couldn't live there anymore I think it
was all radiated or whatever so they
went into space to let it clear and then
they were gonna come back to space but
obviously over time never happened so
any little offense they would float you
they basically just like if you were
over 18 and you created any type of
offense or whatever they would just
float you out into space and Killians so
although there was like a hundred
prisoners who were under 18 so if you're
under 18 they would just lock you up on
the ship so they sent those 100 kids
down to earth to see if earth was good
again because they were running out of
oxygen on
and that's like how it kicks off and
they send him down to speed that just
reminded me that the crimes on the
spaceship it was like anything you stole
like a can of food they would really
blow you up smooth that's it yeah it was
super cutthroat
I've been at skills so basically our
earth in 30 years please no please no
all the global warming you're right
Jonathan that is Bing
I'm in a predicament for this particular
mission because the Pirates in order for
me to escape I need to disconnect the
Pirates Heather I think that might be
different oh [ __ ] he doesn't care proxy
me
wait is that the pirate or is that we
lost her height and then it was a rap
she was no longer than intimidating I
didn't mean all the sandwiches so like I
said I had never encountered pirates
before because I was always able to
either avoid them or shoot them down
ahead of time with missiles
[Music]
Mabel Jackson consumption of growth
hormones during office hours see one
extra help though
that's her perk cool can get down with
that
closest at least it wasn't a space whale
yeah at least I tried first bins like I
heard crimes crimes yeah here for it
it's also a crime but I can't get
oh yeah there Derek says this reminds me
thirteen which you mentioned earlier
also with every death there's a birth
that is true skills very poetic our
Betty Crocker on I should probably think
ahead of time before I started building
parts I have seven hundred fifty health
so that's really good matter if I just
lose it all to true okay so we have a
senior scribe spook and agloe Trotter
glue charters are what what did they do
that's different they're like like
what's a faceless horse but it's that
when they splatter they spread out
radiation the accumulated radiation it
does like damage over time oh man I feel
so bad when I was like watching
Chernobyl and I was definitely like man
this damage over time is gonna be
serious I was like we that is so like
all the game terms are just flooding my
brain because they were like yeah this
is gonna be going on for like a hundred
years and I was like that is serious
yeah have you ever seen that show it's a
Netflix show anybody on the stream have
you I've ever seen it also it's called
dark tourists and basically this guy
goes and you know what does touristy
things around all of these attractions
that are like kind of dangerous right so
he took this tour on this like radiated
village in Japan where that nuclear like
plant exploded during the yeah so they
went and like visited a town there was
someone like doing tours and people from
like all over the world went on this
tour and they're walking around with
their
like radiation meters and in the
beginning is like uh you know this area
has been cleared as safe and I would be
worried about anything over point two on
your meter and then at some point later
on in the episode it's like 14 and
they're like is this if you just said
point do you know like really crazy and
it's like you can't see that stuff like
if you didn't have the meter in your
hand and you know officials are like
this is this area you know is safe to
live in or they have areas called
difficult to return to zones and they're
like you could come here but not many
ways that show us pretty cool with this
go so like all these really like crazy
and weird places like abandoned Island
City stuff - you guys should check it
out it's home it's called dark Torres
it's a Netflix show
yes Netflix shows like yeah on whatever
you watch Netflix I got some juicy loot
over here we got some juicy fuel over
here
so let's get that and hopefully oh oh
the spooks oh man oh man it's a that
blew up so I killed something try and go
around the other way those are some
fresh air yeah yeah so I'm gonna loop
around try to get all this stuff by
going through security hopefully I don't
run into so good smooth sailing
that's cool so now you just can't walk
over to that area I've been hearing the
Sun way too much house ablaze [ __ ]
spooks dog would be he's been creasing
did that kill him
I don't think maybe maybe pretty bad
move on he's invisible I can't see he's
right there
Melissa says I wish this was on ps4
being cool I was actually on the ps4
store searching for those only where is
it oh wait oh no I'm just gonna run
through its no other way I gotta get
that loop baby look at all this dog all
right this is this juice juicy loot
right here pay for it we barely I don't
know no I come out here for a second
control collar okay that's a build
something yeah just came to game pass
worth the download I would say so yeah
you already have
my boy Mike McCarty did a video on this
about how it breaks genre vacations good
video I ran away so I do something new
every time I'm accumulating a lot of
radiation but I'm not gonna worry about
that and one would do is before I
returned clear out my radiation yeah
okay we're on the other side though so
go a long way to go yeah but it's bad
but there's a lot of good [ __ ] out here
I'm Jana no we're gonna find eight
sandwiches again I know that was so
clutch or it could have been pledged
country says cool he's in download an
awesome give a shot hope you enjoy I
kind of like that you know like Xbox
Live and PSN they've been having like
these free games to like are
opportunities for you to get slate games
for free it's really clutch do anything
I could just download and play over cook
to just came out for the PlayStation
free game yeah I love that very good
cuz you know local co-op games like good
one you say so what a good one comes
around do it
so I keep checking my map because I need
my dumbass that's all right we're tanky
yeah that's all steak it seemed like
okay I do have a lot of help but I don't
want to waste it still okay kind of
blocked off my path now man now I'm
surrounded by radiation well I can take
out a little bit that's kind of a lot I
just got to get hey it was a good haul
though you got lots of fuel
oh we did good
almost eat you look at six sweet in a
finger and an eyeball in a plastic
package and working that give you a
chance to warp places without a jumpers
let me I haven't gotten work
hey AJ this is on Xbox one and PC
playing on PC right now our platinum
piece you got yourself Xbox game pass do
yourself a favor and check this out
highly recommend so anyone had the chat
know what a warp key does if so let me
know I haven't done that yet maybe like
hover over one of the other ships that
are far away and see if it gives you
like Oh aha good cause I don't warp
straight to the one getting the bounce
ball great how far does it cats all can
track the map um see that's how they
stop you from exploiting the warp key
it's like you can work anything on this
map hello I want to go to the crowbar
come on it's cool cuz he oh I don't have
enough money I don't really have money
though they have stuff to sell
I think so also you got a yeah you got
free fuel on free sandwich when you go
there nice
what a deal but I do have to go down
this way and I don't want to cross the
new combined options maybe I can stop
here because I could deal with this
would subscribe to tourists maybe get
some more stuff they don't [ __ ] it how
much total sure you don't want to jump
here it's dark lights out
all doors locked
citizens from a deeper debt we're doing
it yes cool I could go straight to that
so I'm gonna do that that was a pro
place pro void bastard lead please some
pro void bastards over here
it was vbl top tier pro plays 2019 okay
so I could probably finish this
objective on stream because I need to do
that for all of you out there AJ this is
called void bastards it just came out
yesterday so check it out we can have a
pretty good time at it so far there's a
lot of really cool like items and bombs
the kitty bot is awesome can you bots
don't it's very clutch skills those have
gone by any Lunchables man lunchable
they eat those religiously in
not so much IRL plenty of time
Lunchables man get that much just
snatched on at recess who you got be
careful
yeah that's an earth luxury and this is
space so we only get regular sandwiches
cut and map though that's pretty nice
lol asks multiplayer although this
probably would be really cool Danny
thank you - okay
Jackson is more tanky we must protect
Jackson at all costs yeah okay that was
some [ __ ] but we got through it
have you turned the power though
but that means that security is down
doors are open the so that's that's cool
for now until yes yeah until I turn the
power on everything starts shooting at
me so I should probably do that sooner
rather than later
yeah how much does this game oh gosh I'm
just on PC oh you're stuck okay your
taste
yeah you're right you're right you're
right boom can we send some sandwiches
how do you regain your health or is it
just you have to do it gotta live with
whatever live with your decisions
I hate spoons so much I also hate those
things can't go do a roundabout way it's
30 bucks on Steam and if you have Xbox
Live it's on Xbox gamepad
which I personally don't have Xbox light
right now but can't have everything it
would probably be cheaper to buy a month
of Xbox Live and then play this for free
and then oh he popped up right when
you're trying to do something where you
add oh oops I can't shoot them on their
divisible [ __ ] I'm just gonna turn
this [ __ ] on yeah I'm getting out of
here [ __ ] y'all get on my way would
dodge [ __ ] I hate this so much
oh my goodness get out of there I am
playing so bad
it's fine we're tanky we're definitely
on the other side of the ship
I hope I'm not disappointing any of my
fellow void bastards out there because
this is going poorly hey it's rough out
here in space it's going as well as you
can expect it to wait all a security
[ __ ] almost all right let's see what
we're working with that's the main loop
piece right there so want to get that
I've got two minutes of oxygen so so
this is where the really strategy the
game pauses when you look at the map
which is incredibly helpful thank you
for that so what I'm going to do is I'm
a run through this way get rid of my
radiation because I'm a little bit then
I'm gonna go through oxygen get some
oxygen pick up that fuel no [ __ ] that
I'm gonna get them I mean check the do
that get the goods then I'm gonna run
through here pick up the fuel actually
no [ __ ] it I'm just gonna get the part
dead I can't risk this [ __ ] right now I
really can't
I got a minimize risk so yeah I'm just
gonna get the part on dip out right here
that's it yeah sounds like you get a
plan because although we are tanky we
did take some damage so now we're like
average life yeah we expended our our
tankyness which is fine Jackson's been
in that work yeah so Jill says don't you
let Jackson's I got it nice ball boom
easy music here for you the most
I'm sorry I'm gonna pronounce your name
wrong but giorgos asks why don't you
guys live stream more often we actually
live stream Monday through Friday at 11
a.m.
sometimes the times will change
depending on what were playing like I
think tomorrow's community Friday stream
might be a little bit later in the day
because they're gonna be playing a beta
that's only open during certain hours so
fantasy baby and this is something like
that usually it's at 11:00 so please
come on back thanks for tuning in if
this is a one of your first time teen
here we got a whole half a sandwich that
time but it's okay we got the part
we got the part we needed John Jackson
survived we made progress in an hour and
16 minutes we finally made some progress
sorry I took so long but we did it thank
you all let's snow so every time you
complete objective to get a little bit
of some new story so I got a torpedo
which can that helps that destroys
pirates that can we use it to repeat on
a whale oh I sure hopes let's hope it
never comes to I mean he did a dirty
last time to save at least pool yeah
Isaiah Diaz really digging this art
style we agree we've been ranting and
raving about it this little time because
it's just so cool actually before we
build the HR computer because every time
you think every time you build an action
item the objective it takes you back to
the beginning and go through a new set
of objectives okay I don't know if it I
think and I think your items carry over
like your inventory carries over I'll
just Scout see what's out there see if
there's anything we can just easily
because we saw a few on food yes
anything no don't want to go there
don't want to go now what is that oh do
we want a super buff Jackson right now I
have some fuel to food to spare you know
what no I don't want to risk anything
because I don't know if I complete the
objective if I like other things well
you know what let's do it definitely
needs some help oh yeah but also if I
die afterward while I like Jackson's
very good character so yes cool back to
full health now
okay cool
[Music]
it looks like you are in need of another
did you know use of turbo mode requires
a water cooling system how I go again
you have action items obtain body fluid
those rivers and water-based lubricant
alright so now I got some more
objectives to complete my stock
yes box mate Persia is my handle pretty
funny right it was like turbo button and
like a piece of tape that has turbo
written on it like press it super legit
I knew something bad was gonna happen
hey we didn't lose Jackson and she also
did not take any damage from that
explosion so I think that was comes that
kid will Sam will be my rapper name I
can i buy that name
so I've been using the Kissel all time I
probably I'll switch to staplers the
topic I've been using pistol throughout
anytime I played at Mercer cent but
pistols always the best weapon assumed
regular forms has been now that I have
passed through another objective I think
there could be even more variables and
different enemies challenges oh it's got
a medical terminal which is cool I can
restore my health at any time during
that mission but there are quite a few
enemies here I can feel I've dealt with
some spooks that screws earlier
actually we had a dangerous encounter
however Jackson's buff so we're good
yeah actually I I have enough fuel and
food I can do a couple skips
optimisations cause no merits I won't go
I love going to the Ettore ships because
it's like it's themed right yeah it's
pretty cool that each sit like ship has
different like not only just items and
stuff but different
yeah variables like your oxygen last
song you're on this on one ship and
another ship and so on and so forth you
know what I think I can go straight to
the objective ship yeah so you know what
skip all of this do it yeah so I go cuz
I have a for fuel and for flight time I
get there I'm gonna be starving but
that's okay because because that's
another luxury Casino we're gonna get
those sandwiches again sandwiches okay
so this well showed weight torpedo him I
don't know if it's RP don't work oh yes
yes
okay we got boy we're getting this
objective done son wait how close you
have to be to torpedo him I think you
have to cross paths
oh oh did the whale
oh the whale it's a pirate so make sure
that actually that helps yeah this
pirate might go there and get eaten also
Oh
all right what automatically I was like
no oh and we got some whale meat now my
food
alright cool we're gonna dock here
there's a lot of radiation you know what
it's a luxury ship so I'm gonna be eatin
good fam
yeah cuz I'd finish him via torpedo
exactly maybe there will be steak this
time since Jonathan out of catering I
hope so it's luxury that you know steak
is luxury luxurious food Wow
except you know when I'm not even gonna
tell you guys how I like to eat my steak
because every time I sit
everyone always clowns on steak
well-done yes I did I just like it I
mean I've had like I've had medium-rare
and like the one above medium rare like
medium well yeah and then meet it yeah
medium but I don't know sorry that's
alright I can live it still be friends
like at least I've actually tried it
cooked other ways some people I know
that like when they'd have never tried
it cooked every ways I don't know I
don't like that squishy feeling
I got a lot of merits this will cost if
you saw with rocks again we paid twice
as much for his quiz rocks each time
right oh there's no which we call it
there's no uh map to tell me you'll all
lock it up
so I got to do some exploring well done
is basically a big burger I like burgers
too so that also sounds like oh snap we
got a gamble or OPEC money oh that's so
weird oh oh you went every time hey we
need some of these like in Las Vegas
where you just win every time I could
get behind that falling out I got money
to blow oh man
crying that's a good one it's a whale
done
oh hell yeah run away amongst the
radiation it's the risk of what like
this there's a I get rid of my radiation
that's good noise it's like I just
rack it up it's fine lose some health
but you know what I got sandwiches
montañés
oh [ __ ] well well it's like you have to
make a choice radiation or a robot
shooting at you okay we're thank you
wrap the fire oh we got a spoof we got a
smoke - oh you bad oh and now he's run
in we're set the same one right how far
can they go out there oh no oh they're
ganging up on you they're ganging up on
you as we take you down
there it is
all right we're still tanky
everything else is just value-added have
to take another look that way spooks
that now huh well there's a lot of
readings in a matter which spooks that
absolutely what's of those sweets Thanks
we got a minute of oxygen though oh [ __ ]
yeah you're a good call
let's breathe take a deep breath I was
like we got the objective I think I'll
go to the FTL Drive here my radiation a
lot and then I beamed the fat we'll just
about a wrap up the bra guys after we
get that done hey we made out like
bandits on this run though for sure I
need to do okay I'm gonna get my whale
done good man that's gonna be the new
terian whale done stop it you keep it
shoot it
Michael you almost almost ruined our
perfect run like always big pile of
radiation right behind them
only one way out of this room I gotta
jump over that strategist helping me out
this sweet tip these scoops ain't got
nothing on trying to avoid the reason
it's fine yeah just yeah I'm getting
greedy this is the problem all the
batteries hey I think batteries like if
you ever end up in a post-apocalyptic
world batteries are gonna eat the shins
we have a way about closet full of
batteries
you guys know ready good oh my god can
you make a gun that like cleans the
radiation like spray it out no be quick
build that bad boy ASAP let's get out of
here
[ __ ] yeah let's just get out of here
because you know we got these scribes oh
my god oh yeah yeah it keeps all the
papers together got some radiation
damage we know what we we completed it
too you can play it school objective we
only lost like three characters we
caught all those hands yeah we caught
hella hands catch these hands
alright cool that was a successful run
right there we have had we had some some
pretty great failures at the stream but
you know what we're just warming up
all's well that ends well
indeed indeed well you guys that's gonna
wrap it up today for our avoid bastard
stream checking out the game it just
came out yesterday it's on PC and on
xbox so check it out download it if you
have Xbox pass or yeah game pass you
play free but yeah super fun thank you
so much for tuning in and also saw a lot
of returning faces that always gets me
super excited because it means guys are
enjoying your time with us and that's
what we enjoy so we are here Monday
through Friday at 11:00 a.m. so make
sure you come on back and have a great
week and a happy Thursday yeah real
quick boy bastards reviews up on
GameSpot this is also Michael Hardy did
a video on it so check that out so check
out all the good stuff on GameSpot cuz
we doing a lot of work out here and
again like Sam said happy Thursday
he's happy
[Music]
you